siempre amé el mediterráneo quizá porque
soy del norte con esta simple frase el
historiador francés feride nombró del
cambio el paradigma de la escenografía
aquel que decía que el historiador debe
de ser objetivo o al menos pretender
serlo brother sabía que esto no era
posible la subjetividad es inherente a
la condición humana y por lo tanto
también al oficio de historiador
el historiador es intérprete del pasado
y cada uno de nosotros somos intérpretes
en nuestras disciplinas
y somos intérpretes en nuestras
disciplinas
no aprenden no podemos pretender ser
totalmente objetivos vamos a poner un
ejemplo a través de esta imagen en esta
imagen al margen de la calidad
fotográfica nosotros lo somos hay me
cortizo y por lo visto tampoco oradores
como os decía vemos un paisaje una
escena paisajística en principio podemos
entender que tiene una cierta calidad
estética hay unos valores inherentes a
ella cuando yo os digo esto yo estoy
condicionando vuestra percepción de
vosotros tenéis unas experiencias unos
conocimientos previos que marcan lo que
estáis percibiendo en esta imagen vemos
una lámina de agua ahí de fondo de un
bosque de ribera hay una niebla entrando
etcétera pero esto no es real en
realidad estamos viendo una imagen de la
mina de pedroso en terra chá es un lugar
que dejó de utilizarse como mina y a día
de hoy es un espacio prácticamente
inerte entonces esos valores naturales
que presuponía y cerbère la imagen no
son ciertos
frecuentemente la apariencia disfraza la
realidad en este sentido de la misma
manera que no debemos juzgar a un libro
por su portada
no deberíamos juzgar a los paisajes por
sus apariencias
brother reconocía su amor por el
mediterráneo también nosotros
reconocemos nuestra querencia por el
paisaje
somos conscientes de nuestras propias
subjetividades intentamos tratarlas con
cuidado teniendo en cuenta la materia
con la que trabajamos cómo es el paisaje
ya que el paisaje no se introduce en
tres grandes verdades o subjetividades
la primera de ellas es la geografía el
territorio el marco físico que sustenta
el paisaje el cual se puede arreglar
ordenar y hasta se pueden establecer
categorías tipologías y demás pero esto
es lo que nosotros llamamos ficciones
del paisaje ficciones en papel pero a su
vez son necesarias para organizar
proteger y gestionar el paisaje
la segunda es la autobiografía nuestra
propia percepción sobre el paisaje un
poco basada en nuestros anhelos deseos
frustraciones y deseos es extremadamente
difícil de cuantificar y de medir
estamos hablando de emociones humanas y
la última es la metáfora el tópico el
estereotipo que pensamos lo que piensan
la gente del paisaje ajeno es la suma de
subjetividades que forma que va formando
una falsa objetividad común es la idea
preconcebida que tenemos el paisaje
la interpretación del paisaje tiene una
doble vertiente existe un conocimiento
técnico pretendidamente objetivo pero
también hay ese condicionamiento
subjetivo del que hablábamos al
principio
de esta manera
de esta manera y retomando además cada
uno de nosotros tiene su geografía en mi
caso es ese contexto es el contexto
geográfico de las rías altas la comarca
de ferrol en el mío la ciudad de méxico
una de las relaciones más pobladas y
densas del mundo
a su vez cada uno de nosotros tenemos
una biografía la mía está marcada por el
éxodo rural del interior está marcada
por el no tener el de no tengo el de a
me gustaría tenerla pero no la tengo
pero aún así tengo una herencia rural
marcada por los datos familiares en
arzúa y monfero aunque mi contexto es el
paisaje industrial de ferrolterra en mi
caso el sincretismo cultural presente en
latinoamérica
en esta foto que es la plaza de las tres
culturas de tlatelolco en ciudad de
méxico se manifiesta esa superposición
de culturas
pero además tengo un ingrediente
adicional soy fruto de la diáspora
gallega en méxico y en contraposición
con frank yo sí tengo aldeano consello
d'a lama que chester
pero todo esto se enmarca en contextos
más amplios en esa metáfora que decía
adams en esos tópicos paisajísticos
históricos paisajísticos son el paisaje
marinero de redes henares y también el
paisaje industrial la conflictividad
social de fene
paradójicamente nunca fui al mar y que
jamás entre un astillero en cambio mis
estereotipos bueno uno muy famoso el
muro otro podría ser el mariachi el
tequila la ribera maya pero yo
afortunadamente nunca he tenido que
cruzar el muro nunca me he tenido que
vestir de mariachi afortunadamente de
momento aunque sí bebido tequila y me
encanta el caribe
llegados a este punto como es posible
que dos realidades tan diferentes dos
personas tan distintas un venidero de
ferrolterra un chilango del df confluyen
en su forma de entender el paisaje esto
ocurre cuando nuestras capas personales
poco a poco empiezan a converger no la
luz el agua la fauna las texturas los
sonidos y todas ellas empiezan a
conectar en la capa más importante que
son las personas son el nexo de unión
porque sin personas no hay paisaje
entender las capas nos permite
comprender el sentido del lugar entender
a las personas nada es más importante
que las personas en relación al paisaje
en este sentido
otras personas
[Aplausos]
hay un desacuerdo un poco retomando que
realmente son las personas lo que
configuran y bien el tópico famoso que
tenemos ahora entre manos
esas las vacas que son muy famosas hoy
las vacas la idea la idea es que
viniendo de un tópico urbano como es el
gran déficit un tópico urbano como es el
mío
precisamente fuimos a confluir en otro
tópico en ese tópico rural que es la
metáfora que conforma o subido
bueno el suyo es un territorio que se
desarrolla en cinco concellos con
sellado de alhama el de avión
extremadamente famoso y conocido beariz
covelo y fornelos de montes está ubicado
entre la provincia de pontevedra y la
provincia de ourense y es justamente en
esta división administrativa lo que lo
ha tenido en conexión es un territorio
que durante cientos de años estuvo
conectado el camino de arrieros conexión
de rivadavia con la parte de las costas
de las rías altas
este es el subido
en un rasgo en principio muy negativo
como es el despoblamiento del rural en
galicia en este caso le vemos un punto
de valor añadido cerca del 90% de la
población de esta de este territorio
marchó principalmente américa pues
tenemos una diversidad cultural enorme
en méxico brasil venezuela y demás que
se nutre cada año
entonces lo que hemos hecho es montar
una iniciativa un grupo de personas
entre los que estamos frank y yo ahí por
el público están marc y marlene también
almudena pierre joxe que lo que queremos
es visibilizar este territorio desde su
propia identidad haciendo una mezcla muy
interesante basada en la ciencia
ciudadana entre expertos y la gente
local nosotros servimos como
facilitadores no queremos llegar ahí e
imponer proyectos como se llega se ha
hecho a comúnmente no que los expertos
llegan y plantean un proyecto la idea es
trabajar codo con codo con los locales
escucharlos por eso el modelo que
ponemos de iniciativas trabajando en el
modelo del pro común la idea es diluir
los bordes jerárquicos y administrativos
trabajar con los vecinos con las
asociaciones con las administraciones y
con todos los agentes que se encuentran
en la zona
la idea es escapar un poco de ver al
rural como espacio meramente productivo
o como se ve desde hace unos años como
un espacio de ocio pero urbano para las
grandes ciudades
como dice manuel la idea central es
escapar de sus clichés rurales a través
de prácticas instructivas que integre a
todo aquel que quiera participar no
somos un proyecto del uso tampoco lo
pretendemos pero a pesar de eso sí que
tenemos una serie de líneas estratégicas
una de ellas es la creación de marca el
landmark o su ido es un territorio hasta
cierto punto desconocido a través de una
plataforma digital estamos intentando
cambiar esto le llamamos plataforma
digital porque entendemos que no es una
web esperamos que sea un punto de
confluencia del conocimiento con
entradas tenga en todas las direcciones
pretendemos reconocer el territorio
reconocer o su ido en el sentido de
volver a conocerlo estamos en un momento
histórico en el que se va perdiendo esa
conexión que tenemos con el territorio
para eso realizamos diversas actividades
algunas regladas salidas a campo
recogida de datos etcétera pero otras
espontáneas acompañamientos con vecinos
y vecinas que no nos transmiten cuáles
son sus inquietudes y sus subjetividades
en relación a la sierra manuel hablaba
de la diversidad cultural eso entendemos
que es un valor fundamental para hacer
visible
esa riqueza cultural esas dos culturas
de las que manuel es un buen ejemplo
además a través de arte pensamos que se
puede catalizar toda esa diversidad
cultural mediante realización de
actividades de lanzar por ejemplo
estamos en contacto con cerro gallinero
con carlos de gredos que es el
coordinador de este centro de arte
localizado en ávila donde hay una
excelente confluencia entre entre
paisaje y cultura y es un referente para
nosotros en definitiva como decía manuel
lo importante son las personas este
proceso abierto que incorpora a todo
aquel que quiera participar
entendemos que el paisaje es igual que
las personas hablaba manuel de esas
capas que conforman el paisaje también
las personas tenemos capas
yo tengo algunas que para hablar en
público por lo visto no funciona pero en
general sí que vemos similitudes entre
paisaje y personas esa sucesión de capas
que pueden interconectarse pero también
entendemos que las personas son
distintas al territorio el territorio no
puede reproducirse y en ese sentido
todos tenemos una responsabilidad
si un poco nuestra responsabilidad por
un lado es con el territorio hay que
conservarlo y luego con los paisajes ver
la diversidad del paisaje porque cada
paisaje representa la diversidad de las
personas
es muy importante la afiliación natural
que tenemos con la naturaleza está esta
conexión nos viene dada desde desde que
somos desde que aparecimos en el planeta
como especie no esta tendencia hacia la
naturaleza y sus procesos naturales que
se conoce como biophilia por lo tanto
los seres humanos somos una especie de o
física porque construye y ama los
paisajes por lo tanto cada espacio cada
persona cada opinión cuenta es lo que
nosotros llamamos y conforman los
espacios invisibles muchas gracias
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]